what you've never killed anyone
no don't wait a minute no that is what
if I just went no no no I haven't you
well here's where I was going is you've
never killed anybody but we got to do a
video together where you got to play one
of your favorite homicidal mania yes we
did a video for college humor you do
these bad man videos which are so and
they're by the way speaking as a comic
book fan they're also a little
heart-rending in that as goofy as they
are they do spotlight huge gaps in the
logic of Batman and in superheroes in
general sure so as as as as silly as
they are they also very much apply
logically so I did one where I got to
play the penguin and that by the way
here's was also cover these videos not
only is it that I'm playing the penguin
or they did one with the Riddler that
you didn't but it's a Christopher Nolan
version of how he would handle the right
character is right there awesome right
we guys it's wow you'd want to see that
thank you and you are we heard we always
wanted to work with you
Oren Brimmer who writes them with me as
a humorous such a and who is the the
Madeleine Karthi mamak Aarthi and then
who did the makeup of the cat was
incredible yeah that is that is if Nolan
did use the penguin he would he would
look like yeah I know I know and you got
to kind of dream up how like tough and
weird you'd want that penguin to be and
cat God made it happen it boy did she
make it happen actually show that yeah
let's see let's see that it's really
creepy looking ha wait wait you you
can't be this you think you think
they're sleeping poor little guy y'all
tell her yeah oh do you do you not know
what Dad is I totally know it is don't
be stupid
let's just let's back it up a little bit
just like him our hero I am
oh my god Batman probably does kill a
lot of people even if when he's driving
around with that motorcycle he's just
shooting missiles at stuff yeah and no
one's died like if you if you rode a
Segway quickly through the grove you
would kill Peter and he's on a
motorcycle with missiles yeah I was
dying